so for those of you who were late to the
beginning my name is Nita Nita I'm a
data scientist in cosmological ok I've
been there for a little over two years
now and about a year ago we were quiet
Baraka and today I'm just going to talk
to you guys a little bit about what we
do in cost-wise why we do it and most
importantly how we do it ok um just a
sec ok so um right back
technical problems ok so as I say most
of my lecture is going to be about what
how we do it and we have a lot of house
so it's going to be really an overview
I'll take questions at the end ok and
next it's something really essential
that you cannot go on without asking ok
so let's just get started so what we do
in cost wise if you try to identify that
multiple devices belong to the same user
to the same person ok
and the reason we do it basically I
think that anyone who walks through the
advertising business or the air
marketing business can think of a bunch
of use cases but one simple legis case
could be just think about all the ads
that you see on your mobile phone
ok how many times do you see something
that is interesting and then you go home
to your desktop and you buy it there
okay so for advertisers before we came
along they would not know that the edge
to your mobile phone worked okay and if
we are able to say okay listen this
mobile phone actually belongs to the
same person and this desktop then they
can know that the ad walked okay so and
this is really just one use case and how
it's done so obviously this is longer
and so but the short answer is that we
have we posted some active amounts of
data okay on a daily basis and weekly
basis and this is just the activity that
data of devices and she'll gave a little
bit of background
this button go into details and we just
we pass this data and we use machine
learning which we all love to get
insights on this data okay and I just
wanna say that we have really an amazing
dev team okay and they do a lot of the
among guided things they do a lot of the
work that involves processing those
they're out of this data and doing it in
a reasonable amount of time and making
sure that we have good access to it
something that it's easy and it's quick
and with the research team can use it to
build a model okay so let's just get
started and talk about the model so this
is basically our world
okay gether either desktop so mobile
phones and those are just notes and we
want to connect those notes together if
they belong to the same user okay so we
have a simple five-step solution okay
first we collect the data the activity
data of the devices then we run a local
model a classifier on pairs of devices
then use another model another
classifier to a neighborhood model okay
again on pairs of devices but just
taking into account other devices close
to them as well and finally we use a
glass model to go from looking at spells
of devices to actually look at the
groups of devices okay two three five
how many devices that you think a person
have and of course last part is to
evaluate what we do and make sure that
it's not just random okay and I just
want to make something clear right now
because I'm going to use this dominate
terminology throughout this talk I when
I say a device it could either be like a
physical device like your mobile phone
or your desktop but two devices can also
have like a felt with two devices also
the same same physical device stainless
desktop but two browsers okay so if you
use both the file in Firefox on your
desktop we will see them we will see the
cookies and we will say okay those of
two devices
so just to be clear clear about that
okay so first step is to collect the
data and this is basically the data that
we have is a device the URL that is its
visited the IPS from which it Elizabeth
and the times which are not in this plot
but also dates and the time of day okay
and the first steps we do is generate
candidates for our model so again our
model is a classifier that takes two
devices and say what is the probability
that those two belong to the same to the
same user and so so naturally we would
ask why do you need to decide how to
generate candidates why not take all
tales of all possible combination of
cells and that goes back to massive
amounts of data no way of doing it okay
so we have to think of some way to
somehow generate the collects candidates
so to speak so one name approach to do
that could we just look at the IPS and
say okay if those three devices share
the knife three then I'm going to make
candidates out of all of those bills
okay and if device 1 and device flow
also Sheldon IP then I'm going to make a
candidate out of this one as well
okay so great we have candidates and we
can now sync of features and we call
them tel features just to make sure that
it's clear that we get a pail two
devices and we're trying to generate
features that refer to both of those
devices combined okay and it could be
either desta to desktop or descriptor
mobile it really doesn't matter
and we regarding the features obviously
I can't give you all of them but
generally speaking we're talking about
the what's the wealth and the length so
the water which will L be as a device
visited what includes three has those
kind of things they went out of the
dates the x part of day part of the week
the calendar day whatever and the world
all since things like which IP was it
was the activity form the state the
country zip code sometimes okay
and one simple feature you can think of
is just how many did I build to device
with a shell between them okay and again
I can't get into all the details
regarding our switches but trust me
there are a lot of switches you can
create so we have the future we have the
candidates and we want to classify to
classify what are we missing
scoffs the labels so the labels we
actually get former partners and what
you get is going to the login data
okay so we get that this device and this
device logged in using the same username
so a natural thing would be to assume
that they belong to the same person and
we get a disservice in this device
logged in from different yourselves so
naturally they belong to the same person
and giving this a giving this little
setting are actually able to run a
classifier and move forward which
classifier to use so I think she has
said extra boost and really extra boost
is super popular super helpful it's
really good it really is very good and
it's used in a lot of cuddle
competitions I better the bunch of blogs
and posts of Alex so that's what you
used up until very recently and recently
we stumbled upon a lig BM which is a new
framework for gradient descent and
unlike HG boost it works
leastwise okay so it doesn't fall clever
wise but whether leaf wise which enables
it to get to more accuracy in less
training time or in the same light on
training time gets to more accuracy or
get to the same at you know seamless
whatever and this is obviously very good
again especially when you're walking
this and also data
what we use it in production but we have
an amazing dev team and maybe they did
some magic
so the danger about like GBM because it
works cliff life rather than level wise
is overfitting
so for all of it's just like an extra
boost we have a lot of parameters that
we can kill but if I can give you like
our advice from what we saw is the
theory has to be much more careful for
all of it ok so here's another of Lisbon
in Dayton Elise MUX this they will all
walk and if you want to speed things up
then of course you have again everything
has a parallel in extra boost or almost
everything has a parallel pelota an
extra boost and of course there are a
bunch of other parameters but I just
can't get into it so ok so we train the
model and it works great we get
predictions and so for each toes of
devices the troll in our candidates I
now have the probability that they
belong to the same person which is nice
and theoretically we could have stopped
here but we can do better so one way to
do whether you look at the neighborhood
of the devices so let's say I'm looking
at those two devices and they have a
pretty strong relationship 0.9 right but
I can look at things like the number of
alternative paths to get from this
device to this device like in this case
there's one alternatives back right and
I can look at things like is this the
what is the length of for this device
and for this device okay so 4.9 it
ranked first for both of them but for
example for in this device you'd see
that this is ranked first for this but
ranked second for this device okay so we
can generate a bunch of features like
that and we train another model again a
classifier okay and we just update the
skull and it filled with this we
generate the training set in the same
way but it's a different training sets
okay that's to avoid the leakage that
she'll mentioned as well
so we'll find the disabled model and
we'll update some scores let's say that
we have naked only guests and this is
great and again we can stop here but
what's a problem with this solution is
that we give it we're still talking on a
local and we're still talking bells of
devices ok so I can say this one in this
one device a end device we will belong
to the same person and device B and
device P belongs to the same person but
then I may say the device a and device C
do not belong to the same person and
this kind of sound fishy so what we need
is just another model a gas model okay
well we actually want to create
communities and say that groups of
devices all belong to the same community
community being the same user and if we
want to define community a very very
natural a definition would be groups of
notes that are internally connected and
loosely connected to other communities
ok so this is what we aim to do and in
this case I think most of us would agree
that there's at least two communities
here like some of you may say no this
one should be its own community but at
least two communities right so this is
great but we can't go over our entire
gas and say whom this one looks like a
community and so we need to decide what
to do so first let's say that we did
have a community we we have some magic
algorithm that says uh videos when I'll
connected and those are all connected so
what you would want to do after we have
the communities is remove the edges
between communities and connect all
internal edges within a community right
just given that we have a community the
edges that connect different communities
will be removed okay I don't want if we
had something to politician and this is
really unexplained
how do we get this petition and so we
get to enough yet another subject that I
could do a complete talk about if I had
a time which is community detection
algorithms so community detection
algorithms is
really a growing field right now there's
a lot of title in on it a lot of
research on it and the life my opinion
the knife's invalid is that a lot of
research comes from different fields so
we get a lot of different perspectives
of the problem a lot of different
solutions it's really useful for fashion
like the glass obviously biology
networks which have no idea what they
mean but I guess some of you ago and
some Tyson got all kind of thing like
that and it so happened that it really
worked well for our problem as well so
we did some research about it we did
some reading cups evaluate your valve
who is sitting here and was leading this
project found a bunch of things that
looked interesting we looked at cloven
for a while it will build in a lot of
places and seem to have good results but
what we ended up using is info up and
specifically it's by implementation
which is called the relax lab okay so
basically you start with each device is
its own community okay and you at each
at each step you do gets to a specific
node so specific device and you can
decide on one of three things since
either you add this device or this
community this device to a specific
community oh you leave it in its current
community oh you could start a whole new
community with it okay and we iterated
over for a while in the original
implementation info map and as well as
in the relax map if they try to minimize
the demotic region okay in our
implementation we use a slightly
different optimization goal simply
because it worked better for our needs
and we also have an undirected graph
because two devices belong to the same
user in both ways okay so we also did
some adjustments there and we relaxed
map which is the parallel to the blue
five generalization which is better
again because we have all this data and
that's about it oh I can again let's
about it for the time we have and so we
have finally our final goal we have
communities which are completely
connected among themselves and
unconnected to any of the other
communities okay and as I said the last
but not least we have to evaluate what
we do and this is where we go back to
our labels again do not use the same
training set the children are doing of
the others we have a validation set we
have the extras and the nobles and
wheels precision in there they call
which I'm going to assume that you all
know but just in case we have a lovely
confusion matrix here and of course the
trade-off between them okay so usually
unless I am able to take my entire curve
upwards I'm going to have to either
giving on precision on Oracle and
obviously if you want more scale you
will have more we call but less
precision but if you want to really be
sure of yourself then you go ahead and
move some scale and in our case we tell
a lot about scale because the earth
business just walks like that they don't
mind showing edge to the wrong people as
long as they do not miss the right
people okay obviously and but again it
really depends on your problem that
you're trying to solve I should mention
that it's not that easy for us because
our label set for many different reasons
which again we do not have time to get
into is very biased okay so first you
need to remember that the back of your
head and then you need to start thinking
of how to account for that bias maybe
you can change it when you're training
maybe you should just when you're
evaluating you should just fix the
evaluation in somewhere in some way just
give weights more higher weights to two
examples that look more like the real
world okay and stuff like that and this
is actually something that we are doing
a lot of a lot of our research focuses
how to measure what to measure inviting
measures everything okay
something else that we look at and is
not in this position illegal trade off
is there the stability of our solution
okay cause we give our clients new batch
of a new solution every week but we
can't tell them in week one the device
alien device B are definitely the same
person and then the week after say no no
actually this is John and this is Jenny
and then in the cervix I no scratch that
they are the same person so we need a
measurement for stability and we also
need to make sure that our solution is
fairly stable okay and again we this is
still an open research subjects class we
are working on it a lot and it's really
interesting and this is pretty much
everything that we've done so far but in
the last year also since we were quelled
by Oracle we started working with other
startups and companies with orc and
acquired in our part of our way cloudy
not a local data cloud so we got a bunch
of new data which are later scientists
love so we have names and email
addresses and physical addresses and
telephone numbers and you can see think
of Smart TVs and PlayStation devices and
all of those stuff so you get much
bigger gas with different types of nodes
none of these nodes is 100% unique okay
you can have two people with the same
name you can have two people sharing an
email or an office email or stuff like
that really nothing I think is obviously
two people living in the same house if
they're married or just to make and
people are always life so basically
you'll get a bunch of their names like
Donald J Trump or emails like blah blah
blah it comes so we need to account for
those and are things that are really
straightforward like blah blah blah
gmail.com but some people like more
sophisticated ly
so stick so you need to think of what
you do with those stuff and we well now
that we have this offline data we need
to think of how can we connect offline
entities
to online entities and this is really a
big question and an open question for us
and it's really really interesting and
really you're useful because even though
people buy more and more stuff online
which is what we serve people still buy
offline stuff especially big stuff ok I
don't think anyone bought a car whereas
from his mobile phone right oh and how
so I don't know stuff like that so here
there is really an opportunity to
connect the offline and online and it's
super interesting and we have missing
data
the missing is not happening in random
because that would be too easy obviously
and very a bunch of open questions but
we have a lot of data and there's a lot
of time so if you have the answers you
can just come pick me in the end and
tell me all the answer that would be
fine
but if you're interested in finding
those answer then we're always hiring
and we would love to have you
that's it yeah yeah right
so of course this is a heart exam for
our algorithms and there's still stuff
because you tend to think that you do
completely different things but I mean
how many times did you read a paper at
home you do that you don't really just a
tool like and how many times were you in
a site that is not completely work
related during your working hours just
one yeah but we don't have login
information of emails and Facebook I
it's not small it's relatively today so
we get it from our partners sometimes
it's actually our customers but it's
really small compared to the entire data
set obviously it's not small like 70 K
but it's more competitive
yeah so so I'm going to tell you the
honest so honestly I am NOT a developer
but as I said and I didn't just say to
say we do have an amazing there's team
and they do a bunch of things that for
me are magic honestly I have no idea
what I'm doing it's not like it's
working and I have easy access to
everything I need most of the time yeah
our label data is biased and it's just a
simple example could be that we get
logging data right but there are people
well really private and they do not log
in from any computer other than their
own and they will never log in from the
mobile phone because maybe two and there
are people just do not buy things online
so they don't have logins for anything
so these are the kind of things that we
may miss in a label data and yeah so
does a bunch of things basically a lot
of the time we'll a lot of what we did
was just trying to estimate how biased
of things during the evaluation just you
have the distal distribution right so
you can see which labels look more like
the real world and just give them more
weight you know doing training or doing
or doing evaluation you can think of it
like as absently the the samples with
the labels that do look like the real
world
oh right yeah
that should be main kind of just by the
common person who I care about my
privacy I don't want to give
corporations the data power to what I
want in my mind won't you recommend me
to do I wouldn't be so then the opt-out
option I am not sure how you do it as a
consumer the customer but I know I can
tell you really what is the best I can
tell you that for now you're safe
because you're only operating on the US
but you can opt out and just ask not to
be added to anything somehow I don't
know how because I know you just we take
the opt outs out because we can do
anything with them any other question
cool thank you
[Applause]